welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham have you ever
wondered what exactly from our real
world exists in the MCU I have So today
we're continuing our mission to catalog
all of the real world people companies
and brands that are Canon within the MCU
in our last video we broke down all of
the art news and media canonized from
phase one and now we're using our egg
hunting peepers to find all the products
and brands that exist in phase one as
well lock up your wallets because these
are all the product placements that are
technically canon in the MCU let's kick
things off by taking a snacky dining
tour of the restaurants featured in
Phase One starting with my favorite
restaurant Easter egg Obadiah stain
brings Tony and pepper a pizza all the
way from Rey's famous Original Pizza in
our world this is the pizza place right
next door the Ed Sullivan Theater where
the Late Show is produced fun fact I was
a page at Letterman back in the day and
we used to get every single celebrity
who came on the show a pie at raised
because it was the best Za in Midtown
when Tony returns from Afghanistan the
first food he wants is an American
cheeseburger from Burger King on the way
to his press conference back on the west
coast again in Iron Man 2 we see Tony
sitting in the hole of the big donut on
top of Randy's Donuts in Los Angeles
Tony also asks Agent Coulson to send his
goons to get coffee from either
Starbucks or coffee bean in Thor there's
a 7-Eleven in the small New Mexican town
where the titular hero lands after being
cast out of Asgard in The Incredible
Hulk we see the Big Slice Pizzeria in
Harlem and down near Grand Central
Station we can see the Pershing Square
Cafe during the Battle of New York and
the Avengers at the very end of Captain
America the First Avenger we also see
advertisements for McDonald's and Dunkin
Donuts in Times Square for loose snacks
and beverages outside full-on
restaurants we've got a whole ass
vending machine full baby for some
reason the MCU loves a good fridge shot
we've got Perrier and Tony's fridge in
Iron Man 1 Arm and Hammer baking soda
and A1 Sauce in Stan Lee's fridge in the
Incredible Hulk Dr Pepper in Tony's lab
fridge in Iron Man 2 and a mini fridge
full of Snapple at the shawarma place in
The Avengers post-credit scene Bruce
Banner runs into a stacked case of
Coca-Cola in The Incredible Hulk and
several hammer and enthusiasts drink
Budweiser Heineken and orange soda
during their attempts to lift mjolnir
from where it fell and Thor there's
advertisements for martini and Johnny
Walker at the racetracks in Iron Man 2
Bud Light in a bar in Thor and a neon
Budweiser sign at a bar where Tony and
Ross have a talk at the end of the movie
The shutari blew up a Dr Pepper van in
the Avengers and we see another Fallen
ad for Dr Pepper and the wreckage of the
Battle of New York during the Times
Square scene in Captain America we also
see ads for Corona Eclipse gum 7Up
Baskin Robbins Canada Dry and Orbit Gum
Jane Foster has boxes of Kashi goleen
Crunch and Honey Nut Cheerios in her
kitchen in Thor and a Quinta Central New
York Sabra hot dog cart gets squashed by
Falling debris in The Avengers now let's
get some boring Brands out of the way
Banks and insurance companies the town
in New Mexico where Thor Matt Jane has a
Bank of America and so does Times Square
in Captain America Captain America also
shows an ad for HSBC The Avengers also
shows a Citibank during the Battle of
New York and a Farmer's Insurance
building is located just above the
shawarma place that Tony takes them to
there's New Mexican visit also shows
that they have State Farm Insurance in
the MCU which means that Jake from State
Farm is a hundred percent Canon moving
on to IRL boss Boys in 616 and Iron Man
2 Happy introduces Tony to Larry Ellison
the co-founder and CTO of the tech
company Oracle Corporation a couple
scenes later pepper and Tony greet Elon
Musk at a restaurant in exchange for
this Cameo musklet Marvel film some
scenes for free at SpaceX going back to
the first Iron Man we see a gray Tesla
Roadster in Tony's car display so it
seems like these two Tech pulleys have
been acquainted for some time this also
probably means that Twitter is as big of
a hellscape in the 616 as it is in our
world as we speak Jen Walters is
probably neck deep in checkmark related
false endorsement queries from Heroes
musk is attempting to troll we made this
video with the help of geology and with
their help you can make your skin
healthier than ever geology is a 22-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
their products are built around just a
handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
geology's co-wash and deodorant are
great and I use them all the time but
right now they're running a special
offer for a skin care sampler pad and
geology skincare stuff is in a league of
its own geology's line of skincare
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging there's
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars 100 to get 100 off of
your personalized 30 day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body product of your
choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
geolog.i.e rockstars100 to get started
but a test Tesla isn't the only fancy
schmancy car Tony owns Iron Man 1 shows
us quite a bit of Tony's car collection
including his flaming 1932 Ford flathead
Roadster in Orange Celine S7 and a blue
Shelby Cobra we also see him driving to
the airport in his Audi R8 in Iron Man
2. we also get a glimpse of a 1949
Mercury Coupe and a 1953 gear Cadillac
in his lab slash garage at the historic
Monaco Grand Prix Tony drives a wolf WR
Ford replica an F1 racing Card
unfortunately that car was destroyed by
whiplash's electronic whips before Tony
could finish the race interestingly in
real life The Monaco Grand Prix holds
the all-time record in the modern F1 era
for the least number of cars to actually
cross the finish line and in the MCU
Tony's name was probably added to the
long list of drivers who never finished
the race also with the Grand Prix is an
advertisement for Bridgestone an
international auto parts manufacturing
company happy rescues Tony from the show
at the racetracks in a Rolls-Royce
Phantom and later on when Tony is
researching Anton binko his Audi R8
spider is also visible in the background
at the end of The Avengers we see Tony
and Bruce Banner drive off in Tony's
Acura NSX like a superhero Sun Howard
Stark also had a pretty cool car during
the events of Captain America the First
Avenger at Stark Expo you see Howard
levitate a 1941 Cadillac series 52 just
before his Tech malfunctions Captain
America himself instead rode a 1942
Harley-Davidson WLA liberators his
personal mode of transportation although
most of the vehicles in The Incredible
Hulk are military Humvees or Jeeps we do
learn that Betty Ross drives a
Volkswagen Jane Foster's research van
from Thor is a pinsgower high Mobility
all-terrain military utility vehicle
originally manufactured in the 1960s by
stare dolomer pooch in Austria its tires
are BF Goodrich brand also I am so sorry
if I messed up the pronunciation of that
Austrian car manufacturer
Seymour Stan Lee tries to pull mjolnir
out of the earth using a Dodge track its
bumper turns out to not be very Worthy
as for car advertisements we see two
Billboards for Audi and Hyundai Elantra
in Times Square at the end of Captain
America during the Battle of New York
and the Avengers we can also see a
couple of Acura advertisements as well
as an Acura being driven through the
chaos but cool cars aren't the only IRL
Tech we see in 616. they've also got a
bunch of our gadgets and electronics the
Incredible Hulk is actually chock full
of tech product placement Banner uses a
Dell computer at Culver University's lab
which is outfitted with Norton 360
antivirus software later on we also see
Bruce using a computer with a Windows
operating system including apps like
Internet Explorer open encyclopedia
recover disk Creator and Adobe Reader
7.0 Culver University also uses Garrett
metal detectors to deter non-students
cursed with gamma radiation sickness
from entering their campus although
Betty gives Bruce a snazzy polar Fitness
F5 heart rate tracker I don't think that
it had the intended effect I mean yeah
he can monitor his stress levels better
this way but it literally beeps at him
every time he gets a boner I feel so bad
for the Hulk he can smash but he can't
smash as I mentioned in part one of this
breakdown the Battle of Harlem at the
end of The Incredible Hulk was actually
filmed in Toronto so one of the other
Canadian businesses we see in this scene
is future shot an electronic store chain
likewise Sam the Record Man is also a
Canadian record store chain in the
Avengers Natasha passes by ajanta
Electronics a text store from India on
her way to find Bruce at the end of The
Avengers we also see JVC Electronics
frustrated that Shield has dismantled
all of her research and Innovations Jane
replies to Coulson that she can't just
buy replacements for the stuff he took
at Radio Shack and Darcy complains that
Shield even stole her iPod caps Times
Square scene has a ton of ads for tech
companies including Samsung Max alley
Electronics LG TDK Electronics Swatch
and Coda actually this camera company is
also featured in an ad outside of Stark
Expo and Iron Man 2 and later on we also
see a Kodak film canister the best tech
reference in Phase One however is when
Tony Stark catches a shield agent
playing namco's 1980 one fixed shooter
game Galaga that man is playing Galaga
thought we wouldn't notice
but we did when Tony leaves a few
moments later the employee clearly pulls
the game back up and immediately starts
playing again now let's talk about some
prominent brands that don't exactly fit
in the aforementioned categories in Iron
Man 1 Tony has a blizzard piano in his
home and an Iron Man 2. you see an ad
for show card jewelry at the racetracks
Thor wears a pair of Levi jeans in his
titular movie and one of the new Mexican
Town scenes there's an okay furniture
store on the street of course we gotta
cover the rest of the ads in Times
Square like American Eagle Outfitters
the Disney Store Forever 21 Planet
Hollywood and the Marriott in The
Avengers we see ads in New York for
aussiebum Southwest Airlines and a
Sephora store the next one I actually
almost didn't catch apparently the case
that Nick Fury uses to transport the
Tesseract is a remella brand topa
suitcase these bad boys are known for
being nearly indestructible in real life
moving on let's talk about some of the
ways that actual organizations are
portrayed in the MCU interestingly NASA
Works hand in hand with shield in space
related metahuman and extraterrestrial
security and research in the Avengers we
see a banner at the Smithsonian that
tells us that NASA and shield have
partnered in the past on joint Dark
Energy missions there's also an ad for
Amnesty International on top of a taxi
in the same movie Amnesty International
is an international non-governmental
organization that fights for human
rights and against societal injustices
lastly we find out that the Boy Scouts
of America exist in the MCU when pepper
angrily confronts Tony about giving
their entire modern art collection to
them it's worthwhile organization I
didn't physically check the crates but
basically yes these are just some of the
prominent companies Brands and
influential people that I found in phase
one of the MCU but I want to know if
there's anything that I missed in the
comments follow me on Instagram and
Twitter whitneypuppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you